it's just been a wonderful ride and
we've had so many different experiences
in so many different stages and we're
just having the best time together
Michael J fox and his wife Tracy pollen
reflect on their upcoming 35th
Anniversary in life as empty nesters
it's empty Nets but it's not really
interesting they're all back tonight
except for asthma it's at school but we
all get together enough that we don't
we're not heartbroken but what it is it
is a new stage in life to be
well it's not as empty as you would
think when you have four there's usually
somebody home so there's like a little
straggler usually but it's fun we enjoy
the stragglers the couple opened up
about their lives during the Michael J
fox Foundation gala for Parkinson's
research where Tracy also revealed how
her husband inspires her I would have to
say every day he doesn't inspire me
because he's human incredible it's more
like can you just pick the dirty socks
up off the floor but so so on a
day-to-day basis I think it's just sort
of a little bit more regular life than
that but if you look at the big picture
and you look at like tonight and and all
of the big things and you know then
obviously it's incredibly inspirational
but we live a very normal life plus
Michael reacts to being awarded with an
honorary Oscar at the governor's Awards
in November for his efforts to help cure
Parkinson's disease that is so exciting
and so celebrating me is is overrated
it's a it's yeah it's there's a lot of
in the last little bit there's been lots
to celebrate and lots of celebrities but
I'm enjoying it the Michael J fox
Foundation has helped raise over 1.5
billion dollars to help find a cure for
Parkinson's Disease a nervous system
disorder Fox was diagnosed with at the
age of 29. well the b word is nice to
see where it is going to be better to
cure
um I think that uh one thing I felt this
time I come into this part of the year
when we when we do this
is that I I I feel it's okay to feel a
little pride and feel like like I'm
proud of what we've done and I'm proud
I'm proud of Tracy I'm proud of all of
our friends that have done this and it's
it's a remarkable thing
[Music]
foreign